when it comes to restaurant choices
Italian and Japanese are well
established on the American dining scene
but something unique has been popping up
in cities Coast to Coast a melding of
the two Traditions called wafu Italian
it's well known in Japan but now chefs
in the U.S are taking it on and making
it their own including Robbie Felice at
the newly opened pasta Ramen in New
Jersey
in this kitchen a melding of tastes and
techniques from thousands of miles apart
Ramen shrimp scampi with ponzu tonkatsu
bruschetta and pork chop scallopini
curiosity alone about japanese-style
Italian cuisine known as wafu Italian
had diners buzzing here in Montclair New
Jersey whereas they step inside pasta
Ramen they walk onto the streets of
Tokyo service
Chef Robbie Felice when we hear the name
hasta Ramen it's not like you're just
making Italian recipes with ramen
noodles no absolutely not what the 32
year old is making is fueling the fight
for reservations months in advance if I
make a wafu Italian Dish I put you on
the spot right away and say is it
Japanese or Italian and if you have that
slight pause for three four five six
seconds That's wafu Italian where you
can't really tell me what it is I mean
don't get me wrong there's been times
where I create a dish and if someone
just says oh it's Italian then I'm like
oh like I messed up I have to go back to
the drawing board and I have to make
this a little bit more Japanese so I
definitely think if there's that almost
like slight confusion where someone
can't tell what it is then that means I
did my job right
confusion never tasted so good
a chewy Mochi carbonara Ramen tossed
with Sesame togarashi lemon and parmesan
cheese mixed tableside with egg yolk you
can't just eat it like normal Ramen
all right there's a little slurpiness to
it
you gotta be all slurp it
appreciation of a quick
of a good especially Ramen slurping
isn't necessary for these noodles
croquette Ramen it's basically uh deep
fried Ramen ball
um so we take Ramen and we mix it with
basically a wafu Italian Bolognese
ready I am how do you do this just dive
in you just bite into it
oh wow
that is not what I expected at all it's
going to be nice and ooey gooey when you
bite into it and then we're going over
the top with a shabu-shabu sauce uh tons
of fresh herbs and garlic and then we
just top it off with a little parmesan
reggiano unexpected flavors that help
make the restaurant an instant hit after
training in two Michelin starred
kitchens Felice a James Beard nominee
was inspired to start wafu Italian
pop-ups before throwing open the doors
to Pasta Ramen earlier this year
it's part of a wave of wafu Italian
restaurants showing up across the
country they've been opening to grid
Acclaim and the past couple years
especially but they're far from
revolutionary
in Japan thousands of restaurants have
been spearheading The Culinary Niche
also known as itameshi for decades
everyone has a different version of how
it started including upscale restaurants
turning to Italian food as a cheaper
alternative during heart financial times
but the style is clearly here to stay
at umenia gomon a national chain that
started in the 1970s spaghetti is served
with non-traditional ingredients like
raw egg Nori and grated yams noodles are
also tossed in ham and boost shoots soy
sauce and butter flavors Japanese
American restaurant owner Daisuke
utagawa remembers fondly my first
experience with wafu Italian
oh it goes way back I think I was in
elementary school in Tokyo inspiration
stuck utagawa opened tanari a waffle
Italian restaurant in Washington DC
about a year and a half ago and says
both Cuisines emphasize enhancing simple
ingredients from the Bountiful Land and
Sea there's a lot of similarity between
Japanese food and Italian food
especially in its Approach To Nature
philosophically also I think we sort of
work to enhance what the nature giveth
and this uttagawa says may only be the
start of a new phenomenon a long time
ago there was tempura and Sukiyaki right
the gis brought back and then came sushi
in the 80s it was a novelty like we raw
fish you know so what's next right and
this is easier to understand than some
of the very esoteric dishes in Japan
that you find it's in a perfect position
there
inspiration from Italy's Italian
Japanese Cuisine
Felice first encountered it while
training in kitchen you tried this food
for the first time and you thought I
gotta do this yeah I mean at the time I
wasn't thinking anything of it it was
young you know probably thinking about
what am I going to eat today because I
have no money just traveling around
Europe but I definitely tried dishes in
Italy that had Japanese influences or
Asian influences but you know never
really thought anything of it just like
oh this is cool they're putting Yuzu on
a Crudo in Positano like obviously
there's not Yuzu here but they're doing
it his time there inspired dishes like
cacio Pepe gyoza handcrafted Japanese
dumplings stuffed with a blend of four
cheeses careful it's hot
mm-hmm
there is no graceful way to eat that but
who cares a delicious celebration of the
two Powerhouse Cuisines Oceans Apart
blending together with plenty in common
after all Cheers Cheers thank you for
coming thanks for having me
you know it's funny because when you
think Japanese and Italian food they do
seem so different from each other but it
makes sense whenever you put it all
together and it's all about this melding
so it's not one flavor over the other
well what do we got what do we do oh go
ahead no no right ahead and rightfully
so because we have a few dishes here
from Chef Robbie Felice you're eating
right there the uh kazuri Ramen
alavangala which is uh has clams
pancetta in its base wow that's good
into a miso sauce oh my gosh uh and then
I also want to point out the gyoza that
we were making right there that you have
in your hand Michelle this is the one
you really love yes cacio Pepe gyoza
four cheeses all you need to know